in these scenes black widow's wielding
her weapons
and we can see that she needs a lot of
rotational power so the medicine ball
rotational slam
is a perfect exercise to apply to this
i'm eric johnson i'm a celebrity
personal trainer to
stars like scarlett johansson andrew
garfield
and jonathan groff when scarlett
johansson first got the role of black
widow in 2009
she said that she had never set foot in
a gym so we visited eric to figure out
with the help of his wife melissa
how he was able to take scarlet from
never lifting
to deadlifting 245 pounds
to help prepare scarlett for the role
eric and scarlett agreed on a basic
philosophy from the very first day
focus on strength and functional
movement not looks
so i like to approach the training
more as an athlete we want to prepare
the actor for
anything that's thrown at them so that
they can do what they do best and that's
act
while many movie stars choose to focus
on vanity muscles
eric and scarlett knew that she was
going to have to do some of the stunt
work in these films for herself and that
having practical strength would be
important
confidence is going to be the biggest
thing that's going to translate over to
her becoming a superhero however none of
this was a quick fix
it took scarlett about a year to achieve
her desired levels of strength and
fitness
to achieve her fitness goals the duo
split her pre-film training into three
phases each lasting three to 12 weeks
we always kind of want to be like six
weeks out from our peak
but sometimes we have like longer
periods we might have
12 weeks we might have six months but i
like to break up her training
into kind of different blocks for this
first phase eric says it's about trying
to reset scarlett's body
and building her mobility we're focusing
on contractions and building that
mind-body connection
and developing her aerobic conditioning
with explosive swinging
plyometric movements and muscle burning
isometric holds this phase
sharpens the reflexes and agility she
needs for stunts
a good example of where this part of the
training paid off is this scene from
captain america civil war where scarlett
really needed to be explosive with her
movements
in this scene black widow is performing
one of her signature leg twists
around hawkeye and throwing a pretty
high leg kick
so she's going to need the hip mobility
and the hip flexor strength to nail that
this is a move that she performs a lot
so we do the
90-90 hip swivels to make sure she has
the mobility to perform it well
we're trying to optimize the body to
have mobility at the right places
and stability at the other places so for
this drill
we really want external rotation and
internal rotation of the hips
while integrating the core a nice
upright posture
and we hope that this translates over to
the screen in
black widow's kicks and her punches the
second phase of their training program
focuses
on strength training in the second phase
we're really trying to set down
the foundational strength work we're
trying to build muscle here we're trying
to
improve all her lifts that way we have
more
strength to pull from when we go into
peak power so this allows us to go after
those goals
increasing pull-ups or increasing our
deadlift that way
your body is able to be more resilient
this strength phase has resulted in
scarlet being able to complete a
245 pound deadlift and single leg pistol
squats
a good example of where this part of the
training paid off is this scene from
captain america civil war
in this scene black widow is really
showing off her power with her punches
and you can really see that her leg
strength is being demonstrated
and translated into those punches it's
actually not with your arm at all it's
all through your legs that's where this
carries over
if i want to produce power right it has
to come from the ground
all the way up to that fist right into
the next person
one of the goals we had in our training
was to do a pistol squat
that was really hard for scarlet and
most people in general
so we had to work up to it and we were
able to do it by the end of training
what we did with scarlet would squat to
a box and then we would slowly lower
that box as she got stronger
so this is a great way to develop that
leg strength so that i can get that
rotational power and throw that punch
the third and final phase is all about
getting lean before shooting
focusing on explosive cardio like
sprinting
as well as kettlebell and battle ropes
exercises that increase heart rate while
building
strength in phase three we're trying to
increase her peak conditioning we're
trying to cut back on rest periods
we're incorporating drop sets and
intensifiers
such as giant sets where we might do
three to four
different exercises for the same body
part we're really trying to
peek here from her conditioning from her
athletic performance
from just how she looks aesthetically
trying to become lean and really fit and
really try to put the
finishing touches on her character eric
says that scarlett needs to be able to
do more than simply complete a move
she has to move with ease and fluidity
while being as fresh and powerful in the
first take
as in the 20th take this scene from
captain america the winter soldier
in this scene scarlet's given a full
effort pull out sprint
and just keeping that calm composure
throughout it this is where our
metabolic conditioning really comes into
play
so one way we do that is through
battling ropes
this is a great way to kind of work on
the cardiovascular system so here we'll
work for
anywhere from 15 to 30 seconds good rest
and now on the recovery we're really
trying to focus on your breathing
right trying to get your heart rate down
as quickly as possible
and how this translates over the camera
is like we're trying to
kind of control our face as well so we
don't want this kind of pain face
so that way when you have to do the
physical scenes
you're able to do that and look like a
superhero
physical training is paramount when
getting into shape but diet and
nutrition are also extremely important
we never really stress like specific
macros down to the gram of protein
we keep it very natural we're trying to
figure out one
from a recovery standpoint is she
getting enough calories instead we
made it more flexible we had chocolate
cake and dark chocolate
and doughnuts because it's more than
just filming or looking great but it's
also about living and enjoying
the experience she starts to do this
rope climb she's getting way up
on the way up she knees me in the face
she gets way up she comes down
she's so happy and then she looks over
me and i'm gushing blood
my nose is just pouring out so she is
on the screen as she is off